(crowd cheering)
All right, thank you sir!
All right.
All right, how's everybody,
how's everybody doin'?
(crowd cheering)
All right, and you guys
can all hear me okay?
Yeah!
I know this guy can right here,
boy this guys ears are
so big he's laughing
at jokes from the Yuk-Yuk Club
all the way on the
other side of town.
(crowd laughs)
All right, hey.
And you sir,
You're doin' okay?
All right.
And you're getting
enough to eat?
Is that even possible?
(crowd laughs)
Thank you sir.
Folks I'm sorry, I'm gonna
get everybody tonight.
Nobody is safe, I'm
gettin' everybody
except for you sir, I'm
gonna leave you alone.
Just like your date did tonight.
Hello!
(crowd laughs)
All right.
Okay who's next?
Who is next?
Hey ma'am, I get it,
you have breasts okay!
Jeez I mean look at
this chick over here.
Her cleavage is giving
the Grand Canyon
an inferiority complex.
(crowd laughs)
You skipped me.
Who's, who's talking right now?
Do me.
Yeah hey man, look at that
pink shirt you got on there.
Wow where'd you get that?
Queer t-shirts.com?
(crowd laughs lightly)
It's in support of
breast cancer awareness.
I am gay though.
Okay.
Go for it.
I can take it.
Hmm?
Oh yeah, yeah, no hey, yeah
don't you worry about
that man (laughs).
Gloves are comin' off!
Okay.
Right there, right there.
What's with the
three drinks man?
Alcoholic much?
(crowd laughs)
This is my pain medication.
Of fuckin' course it is.
It's your pain medication
'cause he is in pain.
Right now.
Make fun of the burns.
(sighs nervously)
Make fun of the, what
did, what you say?
Because here's the problem sir,
is it's really dark in here,
and sorry are you burned?
'Cause I can't make it out.
Thanks so much ma'am
for illuminating him.
Thank you.
That's, I appreciate that.
Oh (laughs) those burns?
Make fun of the robot voice.
Sir, I don't know...
Come on, I can take it.
Okay well nah you know what?
I feel like--
Or the wheelchair.
Look sir, there is nothing funny
about you being in a
wheelchair, and we can all--
Oh, but there is something
funny about me being fat?
All right, no, all
right fine, fine.
I've got, I've got it.
I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
I just didn't wanna
go after this guy
'cause I didn't want him
to kill me in my dreams.
Like, like Freddy Kruger.
(crowd gasps)
- [Man] Oh come on.
Cause he, no?
You know, cause you know
how Freddy Kruger's,
his face is burned off?
That's not...
(robotic sobbing)
You asshole!
He said he could take it!
That's what he said!
I thought I could but I can't.
How is this on me?
How do we even know if
he's crying right now?
(robotic sobbing)
(crowd booing)
Well I don't know,
that sound it just
sounds like an electronic sound.
I mean--
The tears.
They burn.
(crowd booing)
He said he could take it!
(crowd cheers)